why your life partner is so important to
your ultimate success I think a lot of
people compromise on their partners
because they're convenient for me not
only wanted to encourage the dreams but
like participate our entire first few
months of dating was just I'm gonna work
all day you can work next to me I think
because we had such low expectations
getting into the relationship it made
candid conversations much easier there's
so many ways to have marriages this is
what worked for me and I am weird and so
my marriage is atypical I like working
all the time and I wanted someone who
would work all the time with me because
if I didn't then I wouldn't see them and
eventually we were looking at each other
be like oh we don't know each other